I was at my local IGA represent
okay well what is that what's an IGA
it's like it's like a corner store oh
okay uh yeah so I was at my local IGA
and I walked in to just by like I don't
know what I was buying some chips or
something uh and I walk out and I turned
the corner and there's just like a room
standing there on the sidewalk and I've
never had there was the most awkward
moment it's like when you like me to
next you know you just I'm just standing
there just maintaining eye contact with
this route not saying anything I'm like
so she's gonna who's gonna make the
first move here like is it you ran right
no I just I was I just saw him and I'm
like all right he's not gonna do
anything so I just walked back to my car
and the room was just chilling there he
wasn't doing anything like like when I
say Rue right like I think most
foreigners when they think of like
kangaroos they think of like the red
kangaroos like the [__] like yeah
like [__] house kangaroos right like
those guys you only really see when you
go out into like rural Australia where
I'm from uh because my my backyard was
next to a national park so we got a lot
of like kind of smaller Kangaroos and a
lot of like rock wallabies uh which are
like just it's like they probably stand
about that tall they're really really
cute yeah wallabies all right yeah
they're just like small kangaroos
basically
um but I remember the first time we used
to get rock wallabies coming into my
backyard
um and you know just like hang out and
stuff and my dad would be like just to
hang out he's coming to hang out yeah
there's like there's lots of wildlife
here let's just hang out see what's
happening
um and I remember there was this like
rock wallaby that came out uh and my dad
was like son
you should go feed him
and I was like five and I'm like Dad I'm
not too sure man he's like the same size
as me
and he's like nah it's a real quality
you want to [__] you up don't worry so
he gave me some bread
and it's just this like it's just this
moment of just like slowly walking up to
this rock wall of you just hand shaking
being like eat it please don't kill me
and then the moment the rock wallaby
took it out of my hand I was like oh God
is real
because it's great he was like fat an
animal yeah well when you're five years
old dude everything is magical and when
you see this like [__] rock wall
would be the same size as you'd just be
like thank you for the gift human it's
like it's like oh you know what animals
are kind of cool
I don't know that's the moment I'm sure
every Australian has had this moment
where like is it okay is it a common
stereotype
that all Australians love animals yeah I
mean I feel like you have to because
it's the survival you have no choice
right
do you guys like animals
yeah is anyone who doesn't like animals
you're in the wrong country
yeah I mean uh I remember the first time
I saw a kangaroo because I've obviously
seen kangaroos on television and stuff
like that uh and then I basically you
know when I went to visit my family in
Melbourne last time I was here I saw one
for the first time and actually just
seeing one in real life just moving
around I'm like my first instinct was
like that's [__] up and let me explain
let me let me cook let me cook for a
second let me cook because I I just just
seeing this kangaroo move around I'm
like okay let me let me try to process
this so in the entire history of Earth
natural selection uh with animals
everyone everyone in every different
continent animals decided yeah all right
let's walk on four legs all right that's
just the way to get around unless you're
a gym then you walk on two legs all
right uh and then in this island called
Australia a little consonant [__]
kangaroos are like yeah just [__]
bounce
how does that make sense how does that
make sense how did natural selection get
to this point that they decided to do
that well sometimes kangaroos do
actually walk on four legs they kind of
like use their front two legs like that
and they just kind of Bounce like that
if they're you know like but that's
their equivalent of like a Sunday
morning walk you know or when they need
a [__] move they're just like all
right [__] the front legs let's go you
know so I mean yeah it is
watching a kangaroo was it was because
like was so weird because I was just
like there was just one deer that just
squat decided I'm gonna do leg day I
just started squatting and that's what
that's why I believe like kangaroos came
from every day is leg day with a
kangaroo isn't the deadliest animal uh
that bird the one that looks like an
ostrich oh the cassowary yeah that one
yeah I think it's the yeah the world's
most dangerous that's not a bird that's
a dinosaur well it's like it is
threatening it's scary I remember when I
was uh up in Cairns why
like in France no
no that's c-a-n-nn yes Kansas spelled
c-a-i-r-n-s
yeah right that's the most Australian
spelling Cairns uh it's like it's it's
basically right where like the Great
Barrier Reef is okay um so when I went
there in Cairns uh I went my family and
I went on this like kind of rainforest
Safari type of thing where uh we we
rented out like a a a
buggy like a full it's basically like
think of a golf cart except it was
four-wheel drive so we're riding through
this and uh and we had the ranger that
was with us you know doing like a guided
tour being like this is the great
rainforests of Cairns and it's beautiful
and it's humid as [__] and I want to die
and and he just stopped the car and he
was like
guys it's your lucky day
that right there
is a wild cassowary
and we look over and this thing is just
giving us the Luigi Death Stare like
just he's like you are not supposed to
be here
and I think even the ranger figured that
out because he after he said that he
paused for like two seconds he's like
we should go
they run this town dude it's so scary
because like they have uh they have
razor beak right yeah it's like super
short actually the most dangerous thing
about it is it's feet because it has
these like three giant claws that uses
it to kick and uh apparently if you get
kicked by a castleware you're just like
you're just done it just looks like a
dinosaur that forgot to die during the
yeah they're like oh [__] where's all my
mates go
are you saying we're the strongest now
oh don't mind if I do I think I'll stick
around thank you very much yeah no
they're scary yeah one thing I've always
been curious about uh going back to
spiders and snakes is what are you
taught to do if you get bitten by one
like what are you actually taught to do
just if we see one I don't know if you
get actually get bitten by one oh uh
right yeah just give up just pray
um I think uh there was a lot of like TV
shows when I was growing up that were
kind of like I because you know I loved
watching like Nature Documentaries like
you know the David attenborough's and uh
you know all those and I think I
remember one of the shows that that was
on I forgot the name of it but it was
basically like kind of survival like
Australian survival documentary of some
sort whereas like what should you do if
you're out of the desert and you get bit
by a spider or you get bitten by snake
like here are the procedures that you
need to go through and I think I
remember I think with a spider or a
snake if you say like get bitten in like
the arm uh I think the first thing
you're supposed to do is like you're
supposed to like wrap up like get it get
your T-shirt or something wrap up your
arm as tight as you can so that the
Venom doesn't go to the rest of your
body is this true it's something like
that right has anyone had to do this
yeah holy [__] who's been bitten by a
snake before
you're like that's what I'm supposed to
do right I'm correcting that yeah yeah
so I yeah so you you're supposed to wrap
it up with like a cloth of some kind as
tight as you can so that the Venom
doesn't run through the rest of your
body and then obviously if you have
reception you gotta [__] I feel like
this really should have been given to me
on the Fly this information like I I
feel really unprepared welcome to
Australia yeah you do when you get
bitten by a venomous snake
yeah the only thing they taught me was
like please don't you dare bring an
apple in our country well [__] we
will kill you do you have any do you
have any seeds have you eaten any seeds
are you sure you didn't bring anything
in the country
yeah we're very uh we're very tired
asses on that I mean it makes sense like
uh because you know Australia has such a
environment where it's like but yeah
I've never seen such intensity oh yeah
yeah I mean I think it's been because
it's happened once before yeah that's
the reason why we have [__] cane
toads everywhere is because some [__]
brought in an insect that ate all of our
cane sugar and was just like we gotta
get rid of these I think they're flies
on mosquitoes I forgot what they were
um but you know they were destroying our
uh our sugar cane which is like I think
we make the most men sugarcane in the
world or something or we export the most
or something
um but these flies are just like
completely destroying all these crops
right there's nothing in the at the time
the current Australian like Animal
Kingdom that ate these pests right so
then some Australian politician or
something was just like so I've heard
that overseas uh there's a specific type
of toad that eats these [__]
we should bring them in
the Australian government was like
that's a great idea Steve let's do it
so then they introduced these cane toads
and sure enough it wipes out all of the
the Flies right but then I guess Steve
didn't think it through that the cane
toad is also venomous and nothing eats
it
so now we just have an infestation of
cane toads that are just [__] up the
country and they're like well
not much we can do about that eh it's
just uh kind of [__] up uh so next
time I think they should just don't
bring any apples in they should just
keep upping it we should find something
else that could get rid of the cane to
yeah and then have another thing ready
to get rid of that thing oh there is
it's called humans okay yeah but you're
gonna lose that war if you uh try right
I mean you lost the Emu War so
I think you're gonna do any better
against cane toads you guys don't have a
good track record against animals no we
don't I mean could you blame us like
what we're the visitors
humans are merely the visitors to this
country it's an animal kingdom here but
that's what I I think that's what like I
think that's what uh at least for me
that's what got me really interested in
just like learning about animals at a
young age is because when I found out
that like oh Australia has this like
such cool unique set of animals that
yeah yeah could kill me at any day but
it's just like casual could kill me
anything casual my life could end but
it's also just super fascinating to like
learn about because it's I don't know
it's [__] cool right yeah